I don't just have sex with random people
cry all the time
I thrive psycho are you serious ever
like when I was like I love you I love
you too no it was like missin she would
be asleep and I'm like this oh my god I
said before because your girl's a
motional beware it was that good that
you're like I have to be okay with my
daughter having sex i day i have to
internalize it but i will tell my kid
though to the masses on yo can you try
to wait for marriage I'm not gonna
chastise her if she doesn't like I'm not
gonna like she's not gonna come in
scarlet letter you're all but I'm gonna
tell them like hey this right here is
sacred whoever takes that [ __ ] make sure
that that purse is important and try to
wait for marriage because it's important
well now if you don't let Daddy know
that you didn't cuz I don't want to wake
up one day and all of a sudden daddy I
have a baby oh hell no yeah I just what
I was trying to do like you know cuz I
was thinking about showing your CSI at
the age of five and the Forensic Files
and then slowly telling her like hey if
you have sex you're gonna die
well I don't want her to one day like
that she's getting married and she's
like today I'm gonna have sex and the
moment she takes off her clothes she
sees like a bloody murders ha ha you
know I want to start on verse Asian I
want her to let me know everything about
her life that she felt that she feels
comfortable with hey you would talk to
me there's no judgement passed on your
father I'm here to help you out but mind
you if she comes back and she goes hey
this is my boyfriend I want you to read
it that's great I'm just gonna come up
to him I'm a whisper in his ear if you
[ __ ] my child I'm gonna [ __ ] whatever
you feel like you're gonna put in my
child's mouth I will stick in your
throat just know just think about I want
my child to suck your dick get some
stick you're gonna suck soon too now
enjoy prom you know what freaks me out
good I worked with these kids they're
not kids anymore like when you're 11
they're [ __ ] adults now well some of
them were telling me stories about how
they're not virgins anymore yo like
literally what am I gonna do so I'm
saying yeah yeah you will pass out if
you have sex like I just gonna go Jewish
come on oh yeah well how was your first
time was it like 20 seconds and you're
done so you know what's so funny I
actually didn't want to have I wanted to
wait for sex until marriage because I
grew up in a Christian family
and so mean says yeah I wanted to have
sex I was a young dude like I wanted to
[ __ ] everything but because of that
really decided me I know that's true I
can't saw an asylum I was like a
hopeless romantic I wanted to have sex
with somebody that I really cared about
i I see past her if that's [ __ ] I asked
her if she was okay but cuz I didn't I
didn't know I don't know the funny thing
is I she goes on it right now I asked
her if I could finger her for no
seriously that's what it is your fingers
right here so now I'm just thinking
about okay everything he did it before
we did it I asked her on the phone if
next time we could try it and then she
said okay and then I asked her if we
could go all the way and that she said
maybe I always give Jews like a lot of
[ __ ] about this because guys always talk
about them [ __ ] like they're the best
thing on earth like their [ __ ] dick
is the [ __ ]
first time they had sex it's like no
time I possible you came in late to
second you know when you know when you
first see a girl Megan it's like holy
[ __ ] I'm saying I'll [ __ ] [ __ ] right
now holy [ __ ] um you know I'm about to
have sex and I look at it I'm like holy
[ __ ] now how do I put this in oh my are
you serious
because the vagina isn't this it's it's
down and up and if you don't you know
what I mean and I hit you [ __ ] not I
was like how do i oh my god how do I
enter into this heavenly cavity oh my
god Oscar huh no I just kind of like
pull around and I was like
oh wait so did you guys end up being
together no we had sex while we were
together we were a couple of them oh
yeah how long were you guys together we
were together body make like 10 11
months no were you [ __ ] you every
single day I think we're [ __ ] too
long where that was like the problem
matter house how in my house
thank God she listened her pencil done
so you're telling me that if a guy came
to have sex as your daughter your house
not okay but you went no but that's what
I'm saying
I'm with the best what I'm saying I want
her to be honest with me and I want her
to wait until she's married so hopefully
that'll at least a minimum be until
she's out of my house
then it's like but can I don't want her
to like go out of college like wall now
it's time to [ __ ] you know like she
turned into a powder on sexy time
seriously somebody to me but asaurus rex
watch
I don't wanna murder